but then also reminding people how many
of our elders have been lost
in all communities but particularly
think about the african-american
community alone
how many esteemed elders have been lost
and a reminder to people you want to
protect your own family
uh this is the only choice it's
pretending the covet is going to somehow
skip by you isn't viable and i think we
really have to give people that
passionate feeling
and dr birth you want to jump in on this
real quick
sure well i couldn't agree more with uh
what uh what tony and uh mayor de blasio
said
um really spot on in terms of the
information i mean this is a
a true miracle of science what we've
seen the fact that we have a vaccine
this early but we've got to listen to
people and we've got to
make sure they have the right
information you know i just want to say
two two quick things here one is
i think the importance of listening here
is so critical because listening is a
way of showing that we respect people
it's a way of saying i see you you
matter
that you have value and many people who
are skeptical about the vaccine
you know are from communities that for a
long time felt very disrespected and
devalued
by society more broadly by the
healthcare profession by the public
health
uh sort of apparatus and so that's one
of the most powerful ways we win back
trust is by taking the time to actually
listen to people
it's a mark of respect but the other
point i wanted to make is about the
messengers
because as important and powerful as the
messages and we've got to get that
message out
exactly as tony put it although i can
never quite put it as eloquently as he
does
but we also have to think about the
messengers and we need a variety of
messengers to really reach everyone
um there are times when you know people
like
tony and myself and mayor de blasio
might be the right messenger
but there are many other circumstances
where it's local pastors and and rabbis
and local nurses and doctors and
other community leaders who are the
right voices and right faces
to be out there and so i think part of
why i think all of you are so critical
as mayors
is not only because you're on the front
lines it's not only because you're
trusted voices on the ground
it's because you have relationships with
so many of these trusted voices and
if we really want to make this
vaccination campaign work
if we want to turn this pandemic around
we will need your help and your
leadership
in in engaging with and mobilizing those
trusted voices in your communities
to be out there sharing what what they
know about the vaccine to be leading by
example and
getting the vaccine and then posting
that video posting that picture so
others can see that they're
again that they're going first and
they're not just asking others to go on
faith
we're going to turn the page just uh
just a bit
and with cities of all sizes uh continue
to be on the front line of fighting the
pandemic and have requested flexible
assistance
so they can be a driver rather than a
drag on
america's recovery we know that
president biden's always talked about
building back better
the conference and mayors across the
nation have welcomed president biden
and other federal leaders support on
this critical issue
of direct investments in our nation's
cities to expedite
vaccine distribution expansion of
testing
uh tracing and isolation strategies and
keep our critical services and essential
personnel running
uh for at full strength during this this
crisis during this pandemic
from your perspective i wanted to know
uh is this
uh very very important right now we
talked a little bit about vaccines but
you know i feel like we still have still
a lot more to do as well this is a
full comprehensive approach we're going
to be all in what do you guys think
dr fauci yeah i mean obviously
something as um
extraordinary as the experience we're
going through
is not going to be addressed adequately
by one element
and i think you correctly pointed that
out mayor stoney
i mean a vaccine is absolutely critical
when you have a global pandemic but if
you look at the other things that are
involved
there the economic situation the social
situation
all of those other things that's the
reason why when
you look at the plan and we started off
the discussion
by talking about the national strategy
that we had the president's national
covet 19
strategy if you read through it
it really touches on those other things
that make it
comprehensive that you alluded to and
that
described so nicely you know a bit ago
during the discussion it's an absolutely
critical part of it so
there's not one element that's going to
get us through it clearly
as a scientist and as a person who helps
develop vaccines i
feel strongly about the need and the
importance of vaccine
but i also am modest enough to know that
that's not going to do it alone
at all and that's the reason why you've
got to look at all of the other elements
that you alluded to
yeah and i have to say um mayor
this horrible crisis has been one of the
most powerful
proof points we've ever seen for why we
need
a universal health care plan for our
nation
we it's not just about everyone being
insured
it's about the ability to get health
care information
out to people from trusted providers
that means we need everyone to have a
primary care doctor
and we need people not to hesitate to
get health care because of cost
uh the the notion that we would
have been able to do things very
differently
if every american had had real
access to healthcare i think this is
going to be one of the conclusions
that's drawn
in the next year or two that this crisis
could have been
lessened uh if we were not a country
that rations health care according to
income so i agree that there's so much
more than just vaccine and we got to get
through the battle ahead but i do think
there needs to be a reckoning going
forward if we don't want to see another
pandemic or if we want to fight back
more effectively in the future
then let's have an honest conversation
about how to get health care to the very
folks who bore the brunt of the
coronavirus crisis doctor bertie that
seems
right up your alley right now i mean
you're you're you're tackling
uh the coronavirus right now covet 19
but
you'll be responsible for all you know
even more beyond this once we get
uh you know to the light at the end of
the tunnel uh what's your say on this
well a couple of thoughts and i couldn't
agree more with what uh
erin de blasio said in terms of the
importance of health care and
and you know and coverage and that's
still a missing piece
for millions of people in our country
and tony's absolutely right that
this is a multi-pronged uh problem that
requires a multi-faceted solution like
there's
that's why there's not one chapter alone
in the plan that the president put out
yesterday
there are multiple chapters because
we've got to do fight this battle on
multiple fronts
but two things i'd say about local local
aid and local support in particular one
is that
you know i think the team really
understands that state and local aid
is absolutely essential and it's a key
part of this next
uh aid package it's because we know that
the this crisis is really
forced uh state and local budgets to go
into crisis yeah and
at the end of the day like you know
you're faced with dealing with
the budget crisis with making ends meet
with balancing
uh that budget figuring out how to pay
firefighters and
teachers and and police officers and
others and
this is you know there are times when
were thousands of communities in 50
states
there are times where we have to stand
together as one nation and recognize
that this pandemic is something we have
to take on together
and a clear way to do that is to make
sure that states and local communities
have the financial support that they
need
but the second thing i just want to
mention on this front also is that
there could not have been a stronger
case for
building and strengthening our public
health infrastructure than this pandemic
we know that public health has struggled
for many years that's not
new uh in the past year but that budgets
for public health were slashed during
the great recession in 2008 and 2009
they never recovered even though the
economy recovered and so you've got
departments that held around the country
that are still understaffed they don't
have the technology they need
and think about this so when these
crises like covet
come upon us and we put out guidelines
that testing should take place in a
certain way the contact tracing
has to take place that people have to be
checked when they travel in or out
of a community the burden of doing that
falls to local departments of health
as all of you know so well as mayors and
this is a time where we have to take a
hard look and say
not only how do we support a local
government in the short term but how do
we rebuild
these departments of health and our
public health infrastructure for the
long term
because god forbid another pandemic
comes our way in a few years
we cannot be a for we cannot afford to
be caught in the same position we are
now
with an infrastructure that is
fragmented with data systems that don't
talk to each other
with personnel that are over taxed and
under supported
uh and with mayors around the country
who don't have the reliable flow of
resources that they need
to address the crisis that's what we
have an opportunity to fix
that's how we use this opportunity to
ensure that we are stronger post
pandemic
than we were even before cobit arrived
thank you so much dr murphy
i know that is music to the ears of many
many mayors from around the country
right there how we build that sort of
infrastructure up
moving forward i know there are a lot of
mayors who want to jump in on the
conversation as well as i stated earlier
uh if you do please use the q a box at
the bottom of your screen
we're gonna actually start pulling some
of these uh questions out now because we
do have a hard stop at 5 30.
our first question is from uh uh
mayor chris bulwich from elizabeth new
jersey
if someone receives the vaccine within
the waiting period
contracts covet 19 what is the advice
or waiting time for the second dose or
the doses
or the dose or does the person need both
doses
and when would that start
well we've had examples of that
and that's you know not an easy question
to answer because there is not a lot of
precedent
for that but what we have said
is that if you've gotten the first dose
and you've contacted covid
that you should go ahead and just get
the second dose
and not just stop off on that because
you probably
had some protection against maybe the
full effect
of the covet infection with the first
dose even though you weren't protected
from infection and what you want to do
is to go and get the full level of
protection
so it's an overlap of the natural
infection and the vaccination
but i've gotten that question asked
multiple times
and upon consideration we feel it
doesn't make any sense not to go ahead
and give the second dose
uh dr martha you want to add anything
there
no i think yeah tony said i think tony
said it all
and i think the key thing to keep in
mind here is that
you know we're learning as we go you
know in this process and
we're assessing the data as it becomes
available and the commitment that
you know we're making is that we'll be
open with the public as to what we learn
and we'll keep refining our responses
you know you know in our protocols along
the way
um but the bottom line is and this is
really important for
uh just to clarify something that tony
has said many many times i know many of
you have repeated to your
constituents as well is that you do not
get
covet from the vaccine and so i know
some people are worried gosh if i'm sick
right now and i get the vaccines they're
going to put more covert into my system
because
we've heard these questions too and the
answer is no uh
what the vaccine does is it it helps
your body produce
a protein that's a piece of the virus so
it can almost simulate
a part of the virus but not the part
that on its own can go about making you
sick
but it stimulates an immune response it
gets your your antibodies you know
up and running so to speak formulated
and produced in large amounts
and it's also worth saying that you know
some people have said gosh i've heard
that people have
felt um worse after the second dose that
they seem to get
more fever more chills etc and i don't i
that while that is true for some people
i don't want
it to dissuade people from taking the
vaccine if anything what that tells us
when you get a stronger reaction after
the second dose is that's evidence of
your immune system revving up even
further
and generating even more of those
antibodies so that if and when that by
the actual virus
comes and tries to attack your body that
you will have
a lot of antibody a lot of defense
mechanisms already revved up
and you'll be more able to defend
yourself
i got another question here from uh
mayor
armin mazzani from keller texas
the question is in my city we have a
good mass compliance and our
schools and businesses are
overwhelmingly complying with covet
guidelines but we have incredibly high
infection rates
and are seeing record hospitalizations
and deaths my residents are asking me
whether
the guidelines matters if so many people
are getting sick
how do we communicate the importance of
these guidelines in saving lives
as we wait for the vaccine
well you know that that's an interesting
question that
transcends the issue of
of covid and protection against it
just because you have a degree of
infection
and you're doing the right thing doesn't
mean
that doing the right thing is not
preventing you from
having an even worse situation than you
already have
you know and that's tough to get people
to appreciate that
and you know that's one of the reasons
why you have to keep showing
that the scientific data show that there
is a positive impact from the
implementation
of public health measures the washing of
hands the wearing of masks
i mean when people comply with that what
they may likely be doing
inadvertently is that they may be in a
situation that i explained a few moments
ago
where they think they're in good
compliance but they say well i can't
wait to get home
sit down and relax and talk with my
friends
because you know they're my friends
they're not symptomatic and not realize
that someone who you may bring into your
home innocently
may have gotten infected with no
symptoms and then all of a sudden you
have
infection within the context of the home
setting and we've actually as a matter
of fact may estonia realize
that that is much more of a problem than
we realized at first
namely is the setting of the home with
friends
with some family and that's the reason
why you're hearing the recommendations
that when things are bad you should try
as best as possible
that in the home setting to not let
anyone
in except the people who live there all
the time
unless you have a pretty good idea
and confirmation that they themselves
are being as careful as you are and have
their own little pod
in their family because often you are
spreading
infection inadvertently even though you
think you're doing the right thing
and mayor let me just add quickly um
no public official should underestimate
the power of their own voice so all my
fellow mayors i mean you just heard from
dr fauci who's
been the single clearest strongest voice
in this country
saving lives protecting lives but every
one of you as mayors has done that too
and made a huge impact i would say to
every mayor just don't stop
as frustrating as it gets as much as
sometimes it sounds like people are not
listening
uh keep letting people know how much it
matters to take those precautions and
particularly
call them to their better angels because
one of the things we saw in new york
city remember in march and april
we were in just the toughest shape but
we said to people
over time you know the social distancing
the shelter in place the mask wearing we
kept giving them more and more messages
of what would work and they did it they
were heroic i always say
new yorkers were the heroes of this
crisis because they answered
the call but we gotta keep putting that
call out there
you know respecting people and calling
them to arms
to finish the battle there you go i
agree with you
i agree with you mayor uh we got one
more question before
i let you guys get some closing remarks
and i want to give this to
uh dr murthy so
kind of give us some insight on how much
communication
uh do you and dr fauci have with some of
the vaccine
manufacturers i know you mentioned it
earlier that there might be another one
that may come along
uh in the future do you two know uh how
many
they expect to have bait and created in
the next two weeks or
next month do you have an idea or even a
timeline could they
is there some expected numbers that you
can give to the public or just
mayors well thanks for that question
mayor sony um
and one thing i'll just clarify for you
is you know tony is currently in the
administration and has been continuing
his work i'm
sort of in a a period where i'm still
getting confirmed by the
uh by the senate so i you know there'll
be a little time before i fully join on
but i'll tell you from my conversations
during transition
uh and i think this is true uh for tony
and the rest of the team as well
we've been deeply involved in
conversations uh with the companies um
on a very regular basis and those were
conversations that frankly started even
before the election to
try to understand just more closely what
the supply was what the challenges were
what the roadblocks were to getting even
more supply accelerated
what the potential failure uh spots
would be that we need to look out for
and plan for
those conversations i think have given
us more confidence that there
is more supply coming and that it will
continue to steadily increase
uh over the next few months and part of
what we've talked about also
is the importance of making bad data um
as
clearly you know available and
transparent uh so that mayors and the
general public can also
see you know a lot of what we're seeing
as well and and can have some confidence
you know about what the supply looks
like over the over the coming weeks
one of the most clear pieces of feedback
that we got from governors
and echoed you know in many parts by
mayors as well was that they needed more
uh information on when the supply was
coming
they needed more than four or five days
notice uh that they needed ideally
several weeks notice so they could plan
accordingly and set up their operations
and we heard that loud and clear
so i think what you will see in the
coming weeks is a greater focus on that
transparency around supply
uh so that you have a better sense of
what we're seeing and also so that you
have a sense of what supply also will be
coming to your state
over the coming weeks awesome also
i i want to just end with you know
providing letting you all provide some
closing remarks but i just want to say
what i've been saying here at home in
richmond
since march that is this is the the
biggest
team project that we will ever be a part
of and it's going to take everyone
uh whether it's our residents our
citizens our elected officials at the
local level
our healthcare officials our frontline
workers
the state and the federal government is
working together do you have any closing
remarks starting with mayor de blasio
for
of the mayors out there who are still in
the fight and ready to go
another uh another few rounds so we get
this thing uh you know
until we get this thing ended up okay
you know i've talked to so many of my
colleagues i and we
everyone's been through hell let's be
clear but what i admire about the mayors
of america who've been
the front line leaders in the fight
against covid is the
the amazing spirit you know the the
just unwillingness to quit no matter how
bad it got
uh and sometimes we we didn't have a lot
of ammunition but people
kept going so thank you because it's
important you know
a lot of times i think mayors will all
agree uh the first thing we hear
from the people our city may not be the
words thank you but let me offer them to
you
to thank all of you for what you have
done but to our federal colleagues god
bless you
uh for what you're doing we could not be
happier to be with you and to have
our president and vice president now in
office i have a simple list that i bet a
lot of mayors in america would agree
on one uh supply of vaccine
supply supply supply that's the number
one concern right now that maximize it
so we really can reach our people
quickly and not have to cancel those
appointments
to stimulus uh making sure the cities of
america get back on their feet
and lead the national recovery uh three
that flexibility that local flexibility
uh
we know how to reach our people
sometimes state and federal rules slow
us down
and no one wants to slow anyone down i
know but give us some flexibility
that second dose giving us freedom and
flexibility around the use of second
dose is a good example will make a big
difference on the ground
while we make sure of course everyone
does get that second dose some
flexibility on timing
and conditions help us a lot and four uh
thank you
for using the fence production act
please uh
use it to the fullest uh because
anytime the supply gets disrupted uh
we lose a chance to reach our people and
save lives i know you all know that and
feel it but you have the power we don't
have
uh make the companies do what we need
and and
could not be in better hands so again
thank you all
thank you thank you mayor thank you so
much uh dr murphy
sure well thank you uh mayor stoney i i
just want to first just say
thank you all to all of you not just for
being here and giving us the opportunity
to
uh to be with you and share some
thoughts but for the work that you've
been doing
from day one uh this pandemic knocked on
your doors uh nearly a year ago
um and you opened that door and you've
been dealing with everything that's been
coming through it ever since then
and i know that one of the reasons i
love mayors is because
not only are you just on the front lines
but you're deeply grounded in the
realities of the day-to-day that you
can't
you can't retreat to a corner and just
push off issues and defer them to
somebody else you are
the folks that people on the ground look
to for answers and for solutions
um and my regret is that you haven't
always had the answers that you need the
resources and support that you need
i i hope that we can change that over
time i hope that you will feel more
supported
i hope that you will feel like you have
a true partnership uh in in the months
and hopefully the years ahead um but
one last thing i just want to call
attention to is something that you've
also seen very clearly and i just want
to make
explicit something that is implicit to
you which is that the toll of this virus
goes well beyond
uh the count in terms of number of
deaths and hospitalizations and cases
but we know that there are invisible
wounds that we have suffered
through this pandemic especially wounds
to our mental health and well-being
which have already showed up right in
our in rising rates of depression and
anxiety
we've also seen rising rates of
substance use disorders and overdose in
many communities as well
another manifestation if you will of the
stress as well as the disconnection from
treatment and resources that so many
people have experienced during this
pandemic
but i think there's an opportunity here
for us all
because this is an opportunity for us
recognizing how many people
are in deep emotional pain as a result
of this pandemic
to step back and realize uh that this is
our chance to have a different
conversation
about stress and well-being and our
mental health it's an opportunity for us
to double down
on building the infrastructure to care
for our mental health in our schools as
well as in our broader health care
system
we know that so many children go years
before their symptoms of mental illness
are diagnosed on average 10 years
we know that even when people have a
diagnosis that getting treatment is
really hard
for a lot of folks in an environment
where insurance companies often don't
pay
enough for that treatment and when
finding a good mental health care
provider is really really tough
and needless to say if you're managing
three or four jobs on top of that
getting that kind of care for yourself
for your kids is almost impossible um
but
i think we have an opportunity given how
many people have struggled and how
deeply this pandemic has hit us
um to really have a different
conversation around mental health one
that destigmatizes
mental illness one that we uh we sort of
we i think ignites the fire uh that we
need to have to put the resources behind
mental health services and hopefully we
can come out of this
with a deeper appreciation for just how
deeply interconnected
uh physical and mental health are and
for and
the fact that it is our in our mental
well-being that we find some of the
greatest resources
for uh doing our work for being there
for our families
or performing in school the way we want
our kids to so
this is an opportunity to think big
about how we recover
and if we do this right my hope is will
come out of this pandemic with a better
public health infrastructure
a better health care system uh a
recognition that we
depend on each other and a desire to
listen to
and cooperate with and build a
relationship with one another and a
commitment ultimately
to ensuring that we are caring for
people's physical and mental well-being
because we need both we can't afford not
to focus
on our mental health thank you dr murthy
thank you for your service
looking forward to the next four years
and dr falchi
well thank you dr stoney well ditto for
everything that
evac so eloquently expressed uh i i
agree so deeply with everything he said
i just want to be really very brief and
say i want to thank you all
for giving me the opportunity to be here
with you on this panel today it was both
a
pleasure and really a privilege
i enjoy very much interacting with
mayors and people
who are really on the front line i often
have said you know as recently as just
yesterday and the day before and the day
before
that the only way we're going to get out
of this
outbreak this terrible scourge that
we're going through
is that if we understand and deal with
what is going on locally and in the
trenches
and that's the terminology i always use
that you can be in washington you can be
in the situation room you can be in all
the exalted places
on the halls of congress and talk about
what goes on
and what we need to do and whether it's
going right or going wrong but the place
where it counts is in the trenches
and you guys and ladies are in the
trenches
so it really has been a real pleasure
to spend some time with you today going
in the trenches with you
realizing and experiencing with you what
you're going through
because only by doing that can we be
more helpful
in that synergy that i mentioned the
president is talking about
when we get the federal government and
the locals together
in a productive way so thank you for
giving me the opportunity
to share in that oh thank you dr falchi
thank you dr murthy
thank you all for your contribution
today and we look forward to having the
lines of communication
to be open uh over the over the course
of time as well as we get through this
pandemic and thank you mayor de blasio
brother godspeed thank you all
take care thanks so much thank you
you